[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 lipdo
votre émission pour rattraper
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines est ravie de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce vendredi 22 mai les caméras
prenant la température dans 70 lieux du
département accueillant du public c'est
l'une des solutions trouvées par celle
des yvelines numériques pour compléter
son protocole sanitaire ou verront leur
fonctionnement dans cette édition
réouverture des écoles des commerces des
petits musées et des lieux de culte
deux semaines après le début des
compliments nous ferons le point sur
cette crise sanitaire avec la préfecture
des yvelines
installation des nouveaux conseils
municipaux la ministre des sports en
déplacement dans les yvelines et une
année exceptionnelle pour le miel
nous reviendrons sur ce qui a marqué
l'actualité cette semaine dans notre
département
[Musique]
pour compléter son protocole sanitaire
le département et son syndicat mixte
scène est venu mérite ont décidé
d'équiper le service accueillant du
public de caméras thermiques 70 lieux
seront équipés au 1er juin
reportage dans le centre d'action
sociale du département des yvelines de
trappes
il y à déjà les masques les
signalétiques de distanciation social le
gel hydroalcoolique à disposition et du
plexiglas pour respecter les gestes
barrière mais le syndicat mixte seine et
yvelines numériques vous voulez aller
encore plus loin dans la protection les
centres accueillant du public comme
celui ci seront équipés de caméras
thermographiques l'avantagent de cette
caméra c'est qu'elle permet de prendre
la température à distance donc on
respecte bien les gestes barrières et on
peut prendre plusieurs personnes en flux
presque tendu j'allais dire puisqu'on
peut prendre une personne toutes les
secondes
cinq cent mille euros ont été investis
par le département pour ces caméras qui
seront installés à l'accueil les agents
seront amenés à prévenir les visiteurs
de la présence de sept caméras ils
pourront décider d'accepter ou non que
leur température soit évalué sans aucun
contact et les données ne sont pas
enregistrées son image qui apparaît avec
un bip sonore qui annonce qu'il a tenu
qu'une température au dessus du seuil
fixé par la caméra ici la température
élevée celle du verre d'eau chaude
utilisée pour la démonstration
mais si c'était celle de son corps un
protocole spécial serait mis en place
on va le recevoir et on va adapter en
fonction aussi de pourquoi il est venu
on va répondre quand même assad membre
autant que possible on voit l'adapter
mais on va déjà lui donner un conseil
vraiment de premier abord en disant vous
avez de la fière on vous conseille
d'aller voir le médecin on peut même
vous aider à accéder au service qu'au
vide
proches ou de voir un médecin l'outil
était avant tout préventif et permet au
personnel d'adapter son comportement
avec les visiteurs les caméras seront
mises en place le 1er juin
d'ici là le personnel sera formé à
l'utilisation de la caméra et au
protocole l'accompagnant deux semaines
après le début du déconfinement dans les
yvelines département classé en zone
rouge
gregory kane a laissé le point avec la
préfecture avec thierry laurent
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous déjà en ce pont de l'ascension
la tentation pourrait être grande de
partir à plus de 100 kilomètres de son
domicile pour le week-end à ce qui est
formellement interdit aussi à observer
moins de prudence avec eux ces beaux
jours qui reviennent est ce que les
yvelinois ont fait preuve de prudence
jusqu'à présent sur le déclassement et
sur les routes globalement oui la police
et la gendarmerie étaient présents pour
exercer du contrôle quelques infractions
ont été relevées mais la plupart des
automobilistes disposait des
attestations nécessaires pour leurs
déplacements
est ce que l'on sait week-end de
l'ascension justement et de la pentecôte
il qui va suivre est ce que la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre dans
les dix mines et est plus forte en ce
moment cette mobilisation est forte
depuis le début du confinement elle
s'est poursuivie avec le déconfinement
elle se poursuivra évidemment pendant ce
week-end prolongé
mais on observe notamment sur les
autoroutes un trafic moins élevé que
l'année dernière à la même date le
déconfinement qui est effectif partout
en france et dans les yvelines depuis le
11 mai quel premier bilan vous voudrez
c'est après deux semaines justement de
ce début de déconfinement il est encore
trop tôt pour évidemment dresser un
bilan complet les choses globalement se
passe dans un bon esprit il est d'abord
l'esprit de responsabilité de chacun de
nous de chaque acteur qui serait publics
ou privés qui participent à ce
déconfinement pense aux élus aux maires
qui ont beaucoup travaillé pour la
remise
l'ouverture des écoles par exemple avec
les enseignants pour convaincre aussi
les parents de remettre des enfants dans
les écoles
donc ceux des compliments il est
progressif et se construit sur la
confiance et dans le dialogue avec
chacun sur les comportements aussi les
choses globalement vont dans le bon sens
il n'y a pas d'incidents signalés dans
les transports en commun bien au
contraire l immense majorité des usagers
pour que leur masse des forces de
l'ordre attendront pas besoin de faire
balisé pour des non port de masques
puisque ça n'aide pas de l'eau ce n'est
pas le cas vous évoquez justement le cas
des écoles 1 55% des villes et villages
du département ont entamé une une
démarche de réouverture de leur école ce
qui représente environ 920
établissements dans les yvelines
nous relations cette semaine le cas de
deux cas suspects de coded 19 à il
encourt qui ont entraîné la fermeture
des écoles vibrante et aussi de l'école
de lavilledieu est ce qu'on en sait plus
sur ces cas suspects ce que d'autres
situations qui sont similaires ont été
rencontrés dans le département des
yvelines depuis la réouverture de ces
écoles alors sur les deux cas que vous
avez vous pu l encours l'enfant et puis
le l'enseignante qui présentait des
symptômes ont été testés ces tests
révèlent ni enfant ni l'enseignante ne
sont porteuses du comité donc l'école
pourra ouvrir normalement dès lundi il
ya d'autres cas c'est normal toute la
stratégie sanitaire de déconfinement
vise à multiplier les tests pour
justement prendre en compte cette
situation est donc naturel que des cas
nouveaux continuent à apparaître et
qu'il soit traité par la rs par les
médecins traitants et puis qu'on prenne
ensuite quand on est dans une école par
exemple des décisions en lien avec
l'inspection d'académie et le maire de
la commune concernée
on rappelle que les yvelines sont
classés comme département rouge sur la
carte de déconfinement en france même si
on sait que la circulation du virus en
tout cas depuis les dernières données
étaient au vert c'est plutôt sur la
fonction hospitalière qui que les
chiffres sont moins bons elle reste
plutôt forte avec 630 patients
hospitalisés plus de 40 en réanimation
sur le
le département quelle est la situation
actuelle dans les ive et est ce que les
dernières données sont plutôt
rassurantes plutôt inquiétante
ce sont les bleus mais que vous venez
d'évoquer les chiffres et que vous venez
d'évoquer effectivement la circulation
du virus d'après les chiffres que nous
avons paré modéré il est encore trop tôt
pour mesurer l'effet sanitaire du
confinement vous connaissez nous
connaissons tous maintenant que dd
d'incubation de qui va jusqu'à 14 jours
donc on n'est pas encore en mesure de
voir cet effet compte tenu de la date d
confinement le 11 mai dernier
quoi qu'il en soit quels que soient les
chiffres
la vigilance reste de mise et la
vigilance c'est le risque à des gestes
barrières c'est le port du masque
lorsqu'on n'est pas en mesure de
respecter la distanciation sociale en
particulier dans les transports en
commun bien sûr mais ça peut être le cas
dans les commerces par exemple même s'il
a le port du masque connais que
recommandée mais il est vivement on va
parler des commerces dans un instant
juste un mot sur cette cellule d'appui
et de suivi pour l'accueil de 19 qui a
été lancé le 12 mai dans les yvelines
elle a pour objectif d'identifier
d'accompagner les malades et leurs
proches le premier bilan que vous
dressez sûr sur cette cellule qui est
installé à versailles elle est il cette
cellule avait fait vraiment partie de la
stratégie de confinement qui repose sur
trois piliers des tests est-ce que
massif dès que les personnes ont des
symptômes et donc je ne peux
qu'encourager vos téléspectateurs à
consulter leur médecin lorsqu'ils ont un
doute ils seront testés ils auront la
réponse
le deuxième pilier de sa stratégie c'est
la recherche des contacts ces faits soit
par le médecin traitant soit par
l'assurance maladie sera la rs dans les
cas les plus complexes pour proposer aux
personnes qui ont été contactés en
contact avec une personne malade de
s'isoler elle aussi dans la plupart des
cas alors à leur domicile
et puis le dernier point c'est justement
l'isolément qui doit être consenti c'est
toujours sur la base du volontariat qui
doit être expliquée il faut expliquer à
chacun de nos concitoyens à qui on
demande de ceux de rester à son domicile
quel est l'enjeu de cet isolement
et puis qui doit être accompagnée et
c'est ce que fait cette cellule
départementale qui va appeler chaque
jour les personnes isolées pour prendre
de leurs nouvelles s'assurer que leur
état ne se débattent pas et qui peut
aussi leur proposer un certain nombre de
services d'accompagnement dans les zones
denses a peut-être du portage de course
ça peut être dans les cas les plus
compliqués un hébergement à l'hôtel
lorsque c'est nécessaire mais c'était
largement le talent n'est pas la reine
la règle celle isolement chez soi quand
c'est possible on vous explique sont les
gestes barrière lequel les chinois un
médecin un infirmier un travailleur
social peut se déplacer au domicile pour
expliquer comment vivre chez soi sans
contaminer ses proches en portant un
masque en ayant une hygiène notamment
des mâts irréprochable en expliquant
comment partager une salle de bain quand
on est malade sans prendre le risque de
contaminer ses proches alors vous
évoquez aussi le cas des commerçants qui
ont rouvert depuis le 11 mai à
l'exception des bars cafés et
restaurants pour lesquelles une décision
sera prise à la fin mai par le
gouvernement les centres commerciaux de
plus de 40 mille mètres carrés reste
également fermées sauf sur autorisation
du préfet des yvelines on a vu dans les
derniers jours la réouverture de
l'espace saint quentin notamment à
montigny le bretonneux est-ce qu'on
pourrait voir pareille décision pour
d'autres centres commerciaux d'autres
grands centres commerciaux des yvelines
je pense à à vélizy 2 à vélizy 2 pardon
à à parly 2 est-ce qu'on pourrait voir
pareille décision dans les prochains
jours alors sur l'espace saint quentin à
saint quentin en yvelines on n'est pas
dans la même situation que vélizy 2 et
paris 2 et ils viennent règles sur ses
centres commerciaux c'est une surface
commerciale utile de plus de 40
kilomètres carrés autour d'un michael
c'est la définition d'un centre
commercial donc on n'était pas dans
cette situation là sur l'espace saint
quentin ce qui lui a permis de rouvrir
en revanche deux centres de très grands
centres commerciaux du département sont
dans sa situation des visites de et
parmi deux qui restent fermés tant que
nous restons en zone rouge doutant que
le texte qui prévoit la fermeture de ses
grands centres commerciaux dans le
département
n'évolue pas c'est la même chose pour
les parcs et jardins pas de réouverture
prévue
vu que le département des yvelines est
placé en rouge ya plusieurs maires qui
demandent la réouverture de ses parcs et
jardins exactement mais le texte est
très clair c'est le décret sur de
déconfinement qui a prévu la fermeture
de ces parcs jardins espaces verts
aménagés dans les zones urbaines des
départements en zone rouge c'est à dire
que les parcs situés dans les zones
rurales du département sont ouverts mais
ça ne peut pas être le cas pour le
moment dans des zones urbaines du
département alors dans le même temps il
ya des domaines je pense à à breteuil à
dampierre en yvelines qui ont soit
ouvert soit qu'ils vont rouvrir dans les
prochains jours c'est l'accès des
décisions qui se prennent au au cas par
cas là pour le coup vous ils sont
considérés comme de petit musée ces
domaines exactement en lien avec les
maires avec des exploitants leur effet
autorisé l'ouverture d'une trentaine de
petits musées dans le département c'est
utile et le château de breteuil à
l'instant cela fait aussi partie des
échanges que nous avons dès lors que
l'exploitant nous expliquent comment ils
mettent en place des gestes barrières
les distanciation sociale qui permette
une reprise de cette activité qui à la
fois importante pour les établissements
eux mêmes mais qui est aussi importante
pour nos concitoyens après deux mois de
confinement de pouvoir sursis gêné dans
des lieux culturels c'est tout à fait
essentiel et avec le respect de ses
gestes barrières de ces distanciation
c'est aujourd'hui aussi un dernier mot
pour clôturer cet entretien thierry
laurent soit les lieux de culte le
conseil d'état a redonné leur
réouverture pour la semaine prochaine
comment cela va s'organiser dans les
yvelines est ce que ce sont chaque lieu
de culte qui décide de la réouverture de
leur côté ce qui est un travail mené
avec la préfecture
d'abord une intense et celle du décret
qu'il va fixer le cadre de cette
réouverture l'importance des réunions
qui pourront le cas échéant être
organisé dans ces lieux ça nous le
verrons au cours du week-end à la
parution du décret ensuite c'est dans le
dialogue évidemment avec les
représentants des cultes que chaque que
chacun prendra la décision
nous ce à quoi nous serons attentifs
c'est évidemment au respect des gestes
barrières des distanciation sociale dans
les lieux de culte pendant les
cérémonies mais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que pendant toute la période de
confinement l'esprit de responsabilité
des représentants des cultes a été
permanent nous avons été façon continue
en dialogue avec les représentants des
cultes présentant département les choix
qu'ils font sont des choix éminemment
responsable donc nous n'avons pas
d'inquiétude sur ce sursaut dialogue qui
se mettra en place sur ce qui sortira
merci à tirer le rend d'abord être avec
nous merci à vous et je rappelle que
vous êtes le directeur de cabinet du
préfet des yvelines depuis le début de
l'épidémie le département comptabilise
473 décès à l'hôpital au 21 mai à noter
également une légère hausse des
hospitalisations +9 en 24 heures
les admissions à règne mation sont elles
toujours en baisse une de moins 24
heures maintenant le chiffre à 45
[Musique]
lundi le feu vert était donné pour
l'installation des maires et adjoints
élus au premier tour des élections le 15
mars dernier les conseils municipaux
entrée en fonction et doivent être
installés entre le 23 et le 28 mai à
saint quentin en yvelines cinq communes
sont concernées or ils iront se fait le
point
le samedi 23 mai à 10h30 la ville de
montigny le bretonneux sera la première
commune de saint quentin en yvelines
installé son conseil municipal
si le préfet des yvelines l'autorisent
il pourrait se dérouler à la grange de
la ferme du manet en présence du public
nous sommes en train d'organiser
effectivement les choses pour que les
chaque personne puisse avoir ses quatre
mètres carrés tels que telles qu'elles
sont demandées par par l'état nous avons
la capacité
étant donné à superficie de la salle de
la grande d'accueillir aussi un petit
peu public donc nous en avons fait la
demande au préfet nous attendons son
retour
et si le préfet elle accepte tant mieux
nous pourrons accueillir un petit peu de
public
sinon nous l'organiserons à huis clos et
dans ce cas là nous nous sommes en train
de regarder pour assurer une
retransmission de la du conseil pour que
le leader bien sûr son caractère public
à maurepas le nouveau conseil municipal
sera mis en place également le samedi 23
mai à 15 heures pour respecter les
règles de distanciation il se déroulera
au gymnase de la malle me donne
l'installation du conseil qui sera
également déplacé à coignières un
conseil à huis clos le lundi 25 mai à
19h45 à la maison de voisinage sa durée
sera volontairement plus courte en
raison des règles sanitaires
l'appellation l'élection du maire tout
d'abord avec là ça va être le pr dirait
la première délibération à l'élection du
maire
ensuite il ya la détermination du nombre
d'adjoints
donc on va rester sur ce que l'on avait
fait précédemment c'est à dire huit
adjoints et le nombre aussi de
conseiller délégué donc nous en aurons
trois ans suite à l'élection des
adjoints et puis ensuite il ya la
délégation des pouvoirs aubert aussi que
l'on va pas très lors de ce conseil et
puis enfin la débilité des élus à
elancourt l'installation du nouveau
conseil municipal se déroulera le
mercredi 27 mai l'heure et le lieu sont
encore à définir
enfin magny les hameaux le conseil se
déroulera à huis clos le jeu
yvan tuer mais à 19 heures salle de
festivités au trait d'union
au total cinq communes saint quentinois
sont concernés par ces installations de
conseils municipaux dans les yvelines 2
115 communes ont désigné leurs nerfs au
premier tour en mars dernier le premier
ministre et le ministre de l'intérieur
ont annoncé ce vendredi midi
le second tour des élections municipales
aura bien lieu le 28 juin une décision
cependant réversible est conditionnée à
une bonne situation sanitaire
une clause de revoyure est prévue le
décret sera présenté le 27 mai et des
concertations avec les maires de france
pour l'organisation et les partis
politiques pour la sincérité du scrutin
se tiendront le 27 mai sera également
présenté un projet de loi prévoyant un
report des élections janvier 2021
si les conditions sanitaires ne
permettent pas ce second tour le 28 juin
à saint quentin en yvelines sept
communes sont concernées les électeurs
devront obligatoirement porter un masque
et les modalités de procuration sur
facilité quant aux candidats ils devront
adapter leurs campagnes aux règles de
distanciation physique mardi une
ordonnance du conseil d'état a imposé au
gouvernement de lever l'interdiction des
réunions dans les lieux de culte dans un
délai de huit jours
l'institution estime que cette décision
mise en place avec l'état d'urgence
sanitaire était disproportionnée et
qu'elle portait atteinte à la liberté de
culte le décret puis le 11 mai restreint
tout rassemblement au sein des
établissements de culte à l'exception
des cérémonies funéraires limité à 20
personnes
le conseil d'état considère que des
mesures d'encadrement moins stricts
peuvent être prises
quelle réaction du côté de la communauté
juive saint-quentin-en-yvelines mes
propos recueillis par wilfrid riche et
tant que je n'ai pas l'assurance que ça
peut se faire en toute sécurité
je ne tiens pas rouvrir c'est à dire que
le conseil d'état a le conseil d'état
revient sur un sur une demande du
gouvernement se met maintenant est-ce
que ce qu'est ce qu'elle est le point de
vue des scientifiques du personnel
médical est ce qu'il est vraiment temps
d'ouvrir un d'ouvrir ces lieux de culte
pour que pour que les fidèles puissent
revenir en toute sécurité sans essence
infecter d'autres ou à voir on va voir
des personnes malades dans mesure où la
pratique du culte on la continue puisque
chacun l'a fait chez soi dès qu'ils ont
des questions de vue et des fidèles
peuvent m'appeler me demander de
renseignement désinformation donc
l'instant est rond continuer à se faire
alors bien sûr chacun chez soi alors que
les sports équestres ont pu
progressivement reprendre depuis le 11
mai la ministre des sports s'est rendue
mercredi 20 mai au centre équestre du
perray-en-yvelines l'occasion de faire
le point sur les dispositions sanitaires
mises en place mais aussi pour rappeler
que l'état est aux côtés de ce secteur
or ils iront et patrick jacques de
dixmude étaient sur place
après deux mois de fermeture le centre
équestre du perray-en-yvelines a rouvert
ses portes pour ses adhérents
la ministre des sports oksana
maracineanu est venu assister à un cours
d'équitation cours qui peut désormais se
dérouler en respectant les règles de
distanciation une réouverture
progressive et pourtant la structure qui
héberge 70 poneys et chevaux a malgré
tout continué de fonctionner pendant le
confinement
c'était une charge de travail sommes
importantes et les bancs les chevaux
continuer à manger il fallait sortir
tous les jours donc c'était un petit peu
un vrai challenge de d'arriver à avec un
tout petit peu moins non parce qu'il y
avait malgré tout après -2 on avait une
ou deux personnes en moins dans cette
structure le manque à gagner est estimé
à 60%
il y a quelques semaines l'état a
débloqué 70 millions d'euros pour les
centres équestres et les parcs
zoologiques sur tout le territoire
on a besoin de nourrir et de sortir de
monter les chevaux donc cette aide a été
conséquente
et puis nous de manière générale le
gouvernement a porté le chômage partiel
et nous y avons inclus au ministère des
sports tout l'écosystème de la plus
petite association jusqu'aux clubs
professionnels l'état souhaite ainsi
inciter les françaises et les français à
pratiquer de nouveau ce sport le
directeur du cpie reste optimiste même
s'il se pose plusieurs questions sur
l'avenir
est-ce que ça va être une priorité pour
les gens sur les reprises et ce qu'ils
ont toujours un emploi est ce que voilà
ces questions si large quand on peut pas
dire youpi c'est la fête on continue
comme faut rester vigilant avant le
confinement la filière équestre était
déjà en tension environ 10% de ce type
de structures pourraient faire faillite
en raison de la crise sanitaire
mercredi le canard enchaîné a révélé que
renault envisageait d'arrêter
définitivement sa production automobiles
à l'usiné de flins sur seine le 29 mai
le groupe doit dévoiler un vaste plan de
2 milliards d'euros d'économies
outre flins trois autres sites sont
concernés en france
à ce sujet la sénatrice du noise sophie
primas a pris la parole en séance des
questions au gouvernement
réponse du premier ministre edouard
philippe nous serons intransigeants sur
la préservation des sites france une
volonté confirmée par le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire qui rappelle
dans un entretien accordé au figaro que
le prêt de l'état a prévu 2,5 milliards
d'euros n'a pas encore été signé et qui
renoue devrait montrer sa bonne volonté
en respectant trois points le
développement du véhicule électrique le
respect des sous traitants et la
localisation en france des activités les
plus technologiquement avancés l'usiné
de flins qui emploie 2600 personnes et à
assembler 160 mille véhicules en 2019
le site produit le véhicule électrique
renault zoé et la nissan micra parce que
leur nombre décliner les nations unies
ont créé une journée mondiale pour
sensibiliser et senozan mais que les
abeilles sont célébrés avec le
confinement cette année elles vont pu
travailler plus sereinement la récolte
2020 devrait être de bonne facture
mélanie poké et patrick jacques de
dixmude pas de chômage partiel pour les
abeilles les butineuses ont été à pied
d'oeuvre ces dernières semaines de bonne
augure pour la récolte avec le
confinement les abeilles noires ont
profité d'un quotidien simplifiée mais
pas seulement
nous sommes sur une année 2020 qui est
globalement exceptionnelle sur le plan
météorologique nos abeilles ont eu cette
chance magistrale de pouvoir butiner
depuis début mars jusqu'à je ne sais pas
encore jusqu'à quel moment mais c'est
une année d'exception en termes de
capacités donc 2
stockage domial de stockage de nectar à
plaisir 25 rue chez berges près d'un
million d'insectes ses abeilles sont
protégés par une confrérie qui fait tout
juste sa première année de création
six personnes la composent on a dans
l'idée de défendre l'environnement et
les abeilles mais surtout l'abeille
noire et il ya très peu de confréries en
france on n'est pas forcément
apiculteurs puisque le but de la
confrérie ou 6 et d'échanger avec
d'autres confréries et de connaître et
de faire connaître les produits du
terroir donc on peut faire venir des
cuisiniers des pâtissiers et tous les
gens qui travaillent autour du miel de
récolte sont organisées par an aux
alentours du mois de mai et à la fin du
mois de juillet à plaisir les abeilles
ont déjà donné 20 kg de miel
les apiculteurs attendent plus du double
pour la deuxième collecte
nous n'offrirons
nous protégerons est bon viendra retour
de notre séquence ça s'est passé nous
vous ouvrons les archives de tv 78 pour
revoir les sujets qui ont marqué
l'actualité de département cette semaine
le bras de fer entre poissy et l'état
autour du centre pénitentiaire de la
commune c'était en mai 2019
[Musique]
la prison de poissy sera t-elle déplacer
une consultation citoyenne numérique va
être lancée le samedi 1er juin par la
mairie pour connaître l'avis des
habitants une décision qui fait écho à
l'effondrement survenu le 28 mars
dernier d'une partie du mur d'enceinte
de la prison notre prison est édifié ici
depuis 18 ans 21 ça fait presque 200 ans
je ne parle même pas auparavant être le
couvent des ursulines dans les années
750 elle a l'âge de ses artères et elle
est de plus en plus dangereuse pour les
administrés ne sont pas l'abri d'un mur
qui s'écroule
nous souhaitons aller plus loin je
souhaite consulter les pisciacais pour
savoir si comme nous ils souhaitent ou
non le maintien de la maison centrale en
centre-ville pour donner leur avis les
habitants de la commune devront
télécharger une application sur leur
smartphone ou sur leurs tablettes
le dispositif sera également accessible
dans les maisons de quartier le vote
sera quant à lui anonyme est unique on y
aura trois réponses possibles
oui non ou votes blancs et nous avons
fait appel à un organisme sécurisé
proposé par notre part entre partenaires
orange pour pouvoir rassembler
l'ensemble des vols en toute
confidentialité clic une personne qui
puisse voter à la fois évidemment les
résultats sont dévoilés le dimanche 16
juin à partir de 11 heures en mairie
sont transmis au ministère de la justice
gestionnaire de la prison il est évident
que si les pisciacais et les pisciacais
aller dans le sens d'un nom maintient
donc d'un transfert de la prison
ailleurs que dans centre ville ça nous
donnerait plus de poids et je veux pas
trop de pression mais plus de poids est
plus d'arguments encore pour valider ce
que nous souhaitions depuis des années
c'est impossible
selon l'élu le déplacement de la prison
sur un autre secteur de la ville
coûterait près de 80 millions d'euros
contre 60 millions pour une rénovation
promise par l'état pour la remplacer
différents projets sont à l'étude comme
un musée ou des espaces verts
[Musique]
avant de se quitter et n'oubliez pas le
7-8 cultures spéciales l'émission fait
le point sur les répercussions du
confinement pour la culture
vous verrez aussi quels sont les sites
qui ont pu rouvrir ceux 7,8 cultures
spéciales est à retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet tv 78 points comme
nous on arrive à la fin de ce set 8
l'hebdo merci de nous avoir suivis votre
actualité locale revient bay lundi avec
le 7-8 journal weekend sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]